in a few moments Brigadier General John
Lewis spelled
j-o-h-n lubis
l-u-b-a-s Deputy Commander 101st
Airborne Division will give a statement
discussing the helicopter crash that
occurred approximately 10 p.m yesterday
29 March 2023
following brigadier general lupus's
statement Governor Brashear will provide
remarks immediately following Governor
bashir's remarks Brigadier General lubis
will take questions during this press
conference names and details of the
service members involved in the crash
will not be released until next of kin
have been notified details regarding the
crash will not be discussed until a full
investigation has been completed during
the question and answer period if you
have a question please raise your hand
when called on state your name and media
Outlet only one question per person I
will indicate when there is no more time
for questions and conclude the press
conference Brigadier General Lewis
good morning ladies and gentlemen and
thank you for being here
I would like to provide a summary of the
training accident that occurred last
night involving aircraft from the 101st
Airborne Division
at approximately 10 pm last night two of
our Blackhawk helicopters were involved
in a crash during a planned training
plate in Katies Kentucky that resulted
in the death of all nine service members
aboard the aircraft
on behalf of Major General McGee and
commands for a major Knapp who are
currently deployed to Southeast Europe I
would like to express our deepest
sympathies to the families of our fallen
soldiers
we are currently in the process of
notifying their families until these
notifications are complete we are unable
to provide specific details about our
soldiers
we appreciate your patience and respect
of the process and we will provide
additional details once all family
members are notified
I would like to thank the First
Responders from tree County and the
Kentucky State Police for the rapid and
professional response and for their
continued support
the Army has deployed an aircraft safety
team from Fort Rucker Alabama who will
arrive later today and will immediately
initiate an investigation to help us
understand what caused this crash in
order to prevent accidents like this
from happening again
this is a truly tragic loss for our
families our division and Fort Campbell
and our number one priority is caring
for the families and the soldiers within
our combat Aviation Brigade
our entire Fort Campbell Community is
surging resources and support and our
thoughts and prayers are with these
families and these soldiers during this
difficult time
ladies and gentlemen Governor beshear
would like to deliver some short remarks
good morning
today is a tough and a tragic day for
Kentucky
for the Fort Campbell
and for the 101st
the nine individuals we lost are
children of God
they will be mourned and missed by their
families by their communities
we are blessed to live in the freest
country in the history of planet Earth
but we must remember that that freedom
relies on those who are willing to serve
some of which pay the ultimate price
we know a lot about lost in Kentucky
especially these last three years
we're going to do what we always do
we're going to wrap our arms around
these families
and we're going to be there with them
not just for the days but the weeks and
the months and the years to come
we're going to let them know that they
are loved
they are special
and if they'll allow us to carry some of
their grief we'll do that for as long as
we can
my faith teaches me that while while the
body is Mortal the soul is eternal and
we will see them again
this morning I talked to Governor Bill
Lee who expressed his grief for this
loss and his similar commitment to these
families there are no state lines when
it comes to taking care of these
families and helping them with their
grief
finally I also want to thank the First
Responders who came from the entire
region they're on the ground immediately
after this incident doing everything
that they could the First Responders
included the Kentucky State Police Trigg
County Emergency Management Trigg and
Christian County Sheriff's offices Trigg
and Marshall County Rescue squads East
Golden Pond and other Trigg County fire
departments Trigg County EMS and the
Christian County Emergency Management
I said here at Kentucky and I know in
Tennessee we love Fort Campbell we love
all the people that live here and that
work here they are part of our community
of who we are their loss today is our
loss and we're going to stand with both
those that are here today and again
we're going to make sure that these
families know that they are loved that
they are not alone thank you
ladies and gentlemen I'm prepared to
answer your questions yes ma'am
yes ma'am this is a training progression
and specifically they were flying a
multi-ship formation two ships under
night vision goggles at night
yes sir
for folks I'm familiar with the training
exercises is it typical to have that
many people on a helicopter was it five
and four or how many were on each
helicopter and is it typical to have
that many on a helicopter in that sort
of training exercise yes sir it was five
and four and that is fairly typical
there's a pilot a co-pilot a crew chief
and then often you'll have Medics or
other Personnel on the aircraft as well
yes ma'am
um we have a a safety team coming from
Fort Rucker Alabama who specialize in
aircraft safety and specifically these
investigations we hope to have them on
the ground sometime later today and
they're bringing a very diverse and
talented team that will look at every
possible contributing factor and I think
in a short time we will have a much
better understanding of what may have
contributed to the to this accident
yes ma'am
yes ma'am thank you they were all based
at Fort Campbell in the 101st Airborne
Division
yes ma'am
yes ma'am they were a variant of the
Blackhawk
um in this specific these specific
aircraft were a medical evacuation
aircraft however we believe that they
were the action occurred when they were
doing Flying not deliberate medical of
actual evacuation drills
correct
yes ma'am
uh at this point we don't know we're
hopeful that when we get the team from
Fort Rucker here and they're able to
pull some of the data out of the onboard
computers that will have a better
understanding of exactly what happened
yes ma'am
no ma'am
yes ma'am despite our losses we were
lucky because they were able to land uh
in an open field across from a
residential area so thankfully there
were no additional casualties or
injuries as a result of the aircraft
crash
yes sir
yes sir they do have something very
similar to the black boxes that we see
on the larger aircraft uh and and we're
hopeful that that will provide quite a
bit of information of what what occurred
yes ma'am
yes ma'am we we started next of kin
notification early this morning we have
some family members that are in the
local area that we were able to contact
fairly quickly but we also have some
family members across the United States
and a few outside of the United States
so that process is ongoing
um we're doing everything we can to
notify families as quickly as we can but
I don't have a good estimation on when
the final notifications will occur
yes ma'am sir
yeah I don't have an actual response
time but I will tell you that we know
that
um they responded incredibly quickly and
immediately established communication
with our leadership here at Fort
Campbell and then jointly we were able
to
secure that location and get the right
folks there to start helping at the site
yes ma'am
no ma'am there were no transports off
the crash site
yes sir
yes we we had other aircraft in the
vicinity so we were actually notified
via multiple means one was by the Trigg
County
First Responders was was one of the
calls and then we also had aircraft that
were able to quickly move to that
location
and actually stayed overhead for quite
some time
we'll take two more questions
yes ma'am
um then I will have to follow up with
you I'm not sure of the actual date of
the last accident especially to this
extent but I can follow up with you
after this with an answer
yes ma'am
yeah that's that's a great question
everything we do
um safety is integrated into this and uh
for context when we do any training but
especially Aviation training they do
very very detailed planning very
detailed rehearsals depending on the
risk of the operation they're doing has
different levels of approval from the
command
so we will always relook our safety
precautions and our measures but this
was uh like all of these training events
safety is a primary focus for us
thank you
thank you all for attending this
concludes the press conference you'll be
able to find a press kit with a QR code
you're provided if you didn't get one I
will provide one to you thank you